margot robbie opens up about taking on
the role of Tonya Harding in AI Tonya it
scared the haters always say Tonya tell
the truth there's no such thing as truth
et spoke with the 27 year old actress on
Tuesday in New York at the premiere of
her new film based on the former figure
skaters life
it's scary playing a real-life person
especially when that person is still
very much alive and and you know
everyone has a recollection of what they
think happened and it's kind of fun and
interesting to show a different side of
that story and maybe a side to Tonya
that people weren't expecting to see the
press wanted me to be the pile of crap I
never did this
Margo also revealed the challenges of
filming those difficult scenes with her
co-stars Allison Janney and Sebastian
Stan it's about someone you have
complete trust with same without sand we
had a lot of physical scenes and Craig a
director really created a safe place on
set and never he never searched for the
punchline he never searched for like the
funny moments and really just told us to
find the truth in our characters and the
truth sometimes can be very entertaining
Robbie is also pulling double-duty she
not only stars in I Tanya but she also
produced it I was actually saying how
amazing it is to have to be working on
the business side as well as the
creative side I love having a production
company yeah it's a lot of work but I
love it I know everyone's like why are
you having meltdowns I was like I'm not
having no
I love that I'm having a great time
[Music]